[Music]
this is nian cat he's part cat part pop
tart
the gif of a rainbow casting feline was
a viral meme back in 2011.
fast forward to february 2021 the
original gift was sold at an online
auction for 300 ether the cryptocurrency
that powers the ethereum network
that was equivalent to nearly 600
thousand dollars at the time
you may be asking how someone can own
the original copy of a gif that was
pervasive around the internet it's
because it was sold as an nft or
non-fungible token which acts like a
digital certificate of authenticity
the market for nfts ballooned in 2020
climbing to a market cap of at least 338
million from about 41 million in 2018
but skeptics are asking whether these
assets are really worth the value
assigned to them
especially if all it takes to view them
is an internet connection
to understand how nfts work first you
need to understand what fungibility is
fungibility refers to the ability of an
asset to be exchanged or substituted
with similar assets of the same value a
simple example of a fungible asset is
currency
say you have five one dollar bills in
your wallet you may not want to carry
around so much change so you exchange
them for a single five dollar bill
the value of your money is still five
dollars regardless of the fact it's now
in a different form
non-fungible assets are the opposite
each one is unique and can't be easily
substituted for something similar
think of the mona lisa it's an original
piece of art it couldn't be swapped out
for say a mona lisa poster from the
louvre gift shop because the poster
doesn't hold the same value the idea
behind nfts is that you have this
digital signature in the way that a
great work of art might bear the
signature of the person who created it
so you can always go and look at the
original and say yes this is the real
one this is authentic
a nft winds up having that through the
blockchain where the information is
recorded
nfts are cryptocurrencies but unlike
fungible cryptocurrencies like bitcoin
they are completely unique
they exist as a string of numbers and
letters stored on a blockchain ledger
this information can contain who owns
the digital asset who sold it and when
it was sold this information is also
encrypted ensuring the nft's
authenticity and scarcity in doing so
they fix a difficult problem for digital
creators on the internet how to make
your creation scarce and therefore more
valuable
so with nfts you wind up having the
scarcity because they are non-fungible
and because of that there is only one of
these tokens that can exist it can't be
traded for anything similar because
there is nothing similar that exists and
so you wind up getting that scarcity and
that limitation which helps drive up
some of the prices
one of the early applications of
creating the scarcity was the digital
collectible game cryptokitties which
emerged in 2017
users were able to buy trade and breed
digital cat collectibles each new cat
was an nft which certified its
originality and ownership
since then nfts have been applied to
video games digital art and sports
memorabilia one example is nba top shot
which allows users to procure a
collection of digital basketball
highlights like a video clip of a
posterizing dunk all highlights are nfts
and have become big business by
mid-march nba top shot had clocked in
over 338 million dollars in sales since
it went live in october 2020
non-fungible tokens are making their way
into the mainstream art world as well
auction house christie's open bidding
for its first purely digital art nft
bids rocketed into the millions of
dollars
people are really excited about nfts
because unlike with the blockchain
underlying bitcoin you can do a lot more
complex things with it you can wind up
setting terms within it such as you know
the original creator upon each resale of
this asset will get x amount or you can
take it and you can have an nft that
itself mints other nfts and it winds up
having all of these really untested
applications
the surface has only been scratched in
terms of its potential
along with all the hype around nfts
experts have raised some concerns one
issue is that not all nfts verify the
person selling a digital art piece is
actually the original creator this is
difficult particularly in online
marketplaces one of the concerns is that
anyone can essentially go on a lot of
these marketplaces and say i am the
person who created this token
and it can be really hard to verify that
especially if you don't know who they
actually are or they're saying someone
that they're not
and some are skeptical that ownership
alone makes digital assets valuable when
it comes to digital art a buyer owns the
original digital painting but the person
can't keep others from copying the image
and sharing or changing it online you've
had a lot of scams in cryptocurrencies
just historically and so the concern is
that you know people are hyping these up
they're saying like go buy these nfps
it's great but in reality you know
there's always got to be a buyer if
there to be a seller and
people might decide all of a sudden you
know let me cash in my profits and
someone's going to be stuck holding the
bag proponents are bullish on the
potential for nfts but critics are wary
that it may be a digital bubble in the
making
you